هذا هو مع تصاعد وتيره الدعم العسكري
الغربي لاوكرانيا يبدو ان الحرب قد تتخذ
منحن جديده وربما نوويا للمره الاولى
اعلنت روسيا انتاج رؤوس نوويه للتربيد
بوسيدون لاستخدامه في غواصه بالجرود
النوويه طبعا نقلا عن مصدر دفاعي فان
روسيا صنعت اولى ذخائر البوسيدون وستسلمها
وتتسلمها الغواصه قريبا جديرا بالذكر ان
التربين هذا ويسمى ايضا بسلاح نهايه
العالم كان قد اعلن عنه الرئيس الريسيفر
الدمير بوتين لاول مره عام 2018 في حقها
قال ان التوربيد هو النوع الجديد تماما من
الاسلحه النوويه يعمل في اقصى الاعماق
وباضعف سرعه اي غواصه او صاروخ اوسيدون
يمكن هو السفر لمسافه تصل الى 100 كم في
الساعه وقوه ثقل الحموله النوويه الحراريه
لديه قارنها الخبراء ايضا بالقنبله
النوويه التي اسقطتها امريكا على نكزاكي
في نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه طبعا هذه
المعلومات دفعت مسؤولين امريكيين للقلق من
التربيض الخالق الذي قد يتسبب في تسونامي
نووي بحسب تعبيرهم فبحسب خبراء عسكريين
فان بالقدور وسفنا اخرى من سفنها ومن
فئتها يمكنها اطلاق ما يصل الى ثنيه 10 من
هذه التربه ذات نحو ساحل الولايات المتحده